creating lifelike digital characters has
become a staple of digital effects and
like all real life movie stars digital
actors need great looking hair
last year JK Simmons who just balled
previous previously most systems
depended on the idea of manipulating
guide has that influence grooming
tonight we recognize a step forward with
wetter digital's barbershop not to be
confused with the comedy classics
starring Ice Cube and honestly was
anyone confusing it with this barbershop
runs an application within my own and
was developed to give the artists the
ability to interact with every single
hair on the screen the artist has the
final set of hairs for intuitive and
precise manipulation groomers can comb
clip curl or shape hairs in a 3d
environment Wow this phase up production
time and allows quicker collaboration
between artists you can see these
beautifully rendered results in the
blockbusters like The Hobbit trilogy and
dawn of the Planet of the Apes and if we
could bring this technology into the
real world you guys would be
bazillionaire I think there's a couple
bazillion airs in this room already to
see a lot of rich looking faces the
Academy presents the technical
achievement award to mark row revelant
for the original concepts and vision and
to Alastair cool and Shane Cooper for
the architecture and design of the
barbershop hair grooming system so
gentlemen please come to the stage
graduations
thank you were gonna say something very
quickly thank you so much the Academy in
the site State Committee for giving us
this award we're all very excited to be
here tonight
barbershop has come a long way from his
film debut where it first started with a
small scratch of packets full patch of
scraggly chest hair - this year's
darling planet the Apes were hundreds of
hairy apes however it's really one part
of a huge toolset that works together to
create what you see on the screen so
we'd really like to thank the entire
whittle R&D crew for everything they do
every day I'd like to also personally
thank my amazing beautiful wife Justine
my two sons William a few and my parents
because they support me in everything I
do
even when my ideas are a little crazy
okay we'd also like to thank the key
developers who thought very outside the
box and were crucial and transforming
barbershop from a proof-of-concept into
a reality and they are Shoshanna
Miguel Sepulveda Paul Roberts and Eric
so Vee and also my family and beautiful
partner here Branca and above all I'd
like to thank them for their faith love
and support
well we like to thank all the weight
artists and especially Nicholas will to
Nicolas goal for best strong
contribution in shaping this technology
thank you to Joe letteri
who cultivated the technical and
creative environment that made this all
possible I would also like to thank all
my family my wife and my daughter's for
my continuous effort and my dog for
providing valuable for references thank
you